Salut !
Vous l'avez compris aujourd'hui,
on va parler d'expériences
qui ont été faites sur le principe
de la psychologie,
pour découvrir des choses,
des grandes théories,
les mettre en application.
Ou simplement les découvrir
pour la première fois.
Et ça c'est intéressant.
C'est tellement intéressant,
je me suis dit qu'on allait
en faire une vidéo
mais en fait, ça vous le savez
parce ce que vous êtes déjà dedans.
Alors c'est parti, Loïc générique !
[Musique]
Je vais vous parler exactement
de sept expériences
et des théories
qui en ont découlé.
Et puis j'en ai d'autres
sous le coude,
alors si ça ça vous plaît,
si ça vous stimule.
Et si vous dites :
"Putain j'en aurais bien
voulu un peu plus".
Vous me le direz
dans les commentaires,
je vais pas faire
un sondage pour ça.
Mais si je vois qu'il y a masse
personnes qui sont intéressées
et que la vidéo aussi
a fait un peu de vues.
J'en ferai une deuxième,
voire une troisième.
Et peut-être même
que dans dix ans,
je ne ferai que ça
tellement ça vous aura plu.
[Musique]
Première expérience
dont nous allons parler,
c'est l'expérience qu'avait
mis en place Lee Ross,
qui a donné l'expression et la théorie
de l'erreur fondamentale d'attribution.
L'attribution est
un processus psychologique,
qui met en perspective
la cause et l'effet.
Et qui les réunit et qui
les met en parallèle, tu vois.
Et donc l'expérience
qu'a fait Lee Ross,
c'est de faire lire
un texte à des gens.
Mais un texte avec
des propos très controversés.
Et il observait, il étudiait
la réaction des personnes
vis-à-vis de la personne
qui lisait le texte, en fait.
Celles qui ne savaient pas que
ce texte n'avait pas été préparé par lui,
qui ne faisait que de le lire,
avaient une très mauvaise opinion
sur cette personne.
Mais c'est là où
ça devient intéressant.
C'est que même
les personnes qui savaient
qu'il ne faisait que lire un texte,
qui n'était pas de lui.
Mais qu'il était
obligé de le faire,
avaient quand même
une mauvaise opinion
et le tenaient en partie
pour responsable,
de ce que racontait le texte.
Et c'est ça qui est intéressant.
En fait, ça vient à cause
de presque l'inverse
de l'erreur fondamentale
d'attribution,
qui fait que quand des choses
nous arrivent à nous.
C'est toujours le fait
de circonstances extérieures,
psychologiquement parlant.
Alors que quand cette même chose
arrive à quelqu'un d'autre,
on en tient pour
entièrement responsable.
L'exemple très classique
qu'on utilise pour ça, c'est de dire :
"Désolé, je suis en retard ce matin,
parce que vraiment
mon réveil a pas sonné
et en plus je me suis couché tard,
parce qu'il y avait du bruit
à côté de chez moi".
Ce qui peut être
complètement la vérité.
Alors que si quelqu'un arrive
en retard pour vous voir,
vous allez avoir plutôt tendance à dire
que c'est de sa faute, en fait.
On ne peut pas
te faire confiance, en fait.
Toi tu es toujours à la bourre
de toute manière.
Et vous allez lui en vouloir
à lui personnellement.
Sans prendre en compte
les facteurs extérieurs.
C'est intéressant, parce que
grâce à cette expérience,
on peut tenir compte
de ce biais là,
qu'on a instantanément
pour essayer de lutter contre
et de s'améliorer un peu.
[Musique]
L'expérience numéro deux,
elle nous vient de 1956,
par le psychologue Américain
George Miller.
Vous allez essayer de faire un peu
comme lui proposait à l'époque.
Vous allez essayer
de retenir rapidement,
cette phrase ici,
toutes ces lettres là.
Allez-y, retenez ça
le plus vite possible.
Stop.
Bon c'était pas facile.
Et pourtant si vous aviez vu
ce qu'on a mis secrètement à l'intérieur,
vous l'auriez retenue.
En fait, c'était juste UPS,
le service postal.
BMW, la bagnole.
CIA, donc la CIA.
Et à la fin, Loïc s'est même
intercalé à la toute fin.
Et si je vous avais dit
ça dès le départ,
si vous l'aviez vu aussi
dès le départ,
ou si on avait mis
des points au début.
Vous l'auriez retenue
instantanément,
parce que c'est que quatre
grosses informations à retenir.
Et c'est ça qu'a essayé de démontrer
George Miller en 1956.
C'est que le cerveau humain,
dans sa mémoire de travail,
n'arrive pas à retenir plus
de sept choses en moyenne.
Que ce soit des mots, des images,
des notes de musique,
la liste de courses, ce qu'on veut.
En général, c'est sept.
Et c'est pour ça, qu'il faut
qu'on divise les choses,
qu'on les subdivise
par plus gros paquets,
comme on le fait pour
les numéros de téléphone.
On retient pas dix chiffres,
on les retient en fait,
par groupe de deux.
Donc on retient déjà
que cinq informations
et là c'est beaucoup plus simple.
Son élève, Sydney Smith,
a lui réussi l'exploit de retenir
40 nombres binaires en aléatoire.
Donc on lui a présenté une suite
aléatoire de uns et de zéros.
Il a retenu ça.
Et après il a expliqué, qu'il avait
tout regroupé par lots de huit.
ça fait plus que
cinq lots à retenir.
Il avait trouvé une petite
méthode mnémotechnique
pour que ça forme des mots,
les suites de zéros et de uns,
ça forme des mots
et comme ça il a retenu.
Et c'est vrai que
ça marche avec tout.
C'est à dire que si on divise
un discours en parties, ou un cours.
Pour ceux qui sont
en cours, en parties.
On retient mieux.
On retient les chansons
par rimes de deux
et après par couplet
et par refrain.
Et ensuite l'ensemble.
Donc grâce à George Miller,
on sait qu'il faut absolument
regrouper en dessous de sept,
pour pouvoir bien
retenir les choses.
[Musique]
Pour cette troisième expérience,
nous allons parler de quelque chose
qui a été fait en 1995.
Une étude très intéressante.
Qui a été faite
avec plusieurs critères.
La première chose
qu'ils ont fait,
c'est de demander à tout un groupe
de personnes noires de peau.
De remplir un test d'intelligence.
Et ils ont pris aussi une partie
de ces personnes là,
à qu'ils ont dit que
c'était un test pour voir...
C'était pas vraiment
un test d'ailleurs,
c'était une étude pour voir
comment réfléchissaient les gens,
quand ils voulaient
résoudre un problème.
Toutes les personnes
qui ont pensé faire un test,
juste pour résoudre
les problèmes.
Ont eu des meilleures notes que
les personnes qui ont eu le même test,
mais qui pensaient faire un test
d'intelligence sur elles-mêmes.
ça s'appelle
la menace du stéréotype.
En gros quand toute ta vie,
tu as été brimé par des choses
pour ton caractère de genre,
ou d'orientation sexuelle,
ou de couleur de peau.
Tu vas faire en sorte que
ce stéréotype s'autoproclame.
Ils sont allés plus loin
dans les études.
Par exemple quand une femme
joue contre un ordinateur,
où il y a un autre être humain derrière
et qu'elle pense que c'est un homme.
Elle joue un peu plus mal,
parce qu'elle s'auto-dévalorise.
De la même manière,
un schizophrène va être
beaucoup plus maladroit,
s'il pense que les autres
personnes dans la pièce
sont au courant du fait
qu'il est schizophrène.
En gros la menace
du stéréotype,
c'est par peur de confirmer
aux autres l'à priori
et le stéréotype
qu'ils ont sur vous.
Et bien en fait,
vous êtes moins confiants.
Et du coup vous auto-réalisez
les choses dont vous aviez peur.
C'est un peu pervers
quand même.
[Musique]
La quatrième étude
s'est passée dans une prison.
Une fausse prison.
Le psychologue Philip Zimbardo,
avait un jour demandé à des étudiants,
qui voudraient être
volontaires pour des études, etc.
Pour remplir des papiers, etc.
Quelques temps après,
il fait arrêter 12
de ces étudiants-là,
par la police locale qui les emmènent
directement à une prison,
sans leurs dire
ce que c'était, etc.
Ils les enchaînent.
Et qui les descendent
directement au sous sol.
Ensuite, il demande à 12 personnes
qui étaient volontaires aussi,
pour les études
qu'il proposait au départ.
De se faire engager pour être
surveillant, maton, etc.
Les 12 personnes
qu'il a recrutées
n'avaient rien dans
leur profil psychologique,
de bizarre, ou d'instable,
ou de sadique,
ou des choses comme ça,
et au contraire que c'était des
personnes qui respectaient la loi,
qui étaient plutôt cools, tu vois.
Il les a engagés.
L'expérience devait
durer deux semaines.
Elle s'est arrêtée
au bout de six jours.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que les détenus
étaient dans un état
assez extrême d'urgence, en fait.
De besoin psychologique,
voire médicaux.
Parce qu'un tiers, donc quatre
des 12 surveillants
avaient révélé
un comportement sadique.
Et d'une manière générale,
les 12 surveillants
s'étaient montrés plutôt
à tendance sadique,
plutôt injustes,
plutôt trop sévères, etc.
Donc six jours au lieu de 12.
Il a fallu interrompre ça.
ça s'appelle
"La prison de Zimbardo",
aujourd'hui, cette expérience
psychologique.
Et elle révèle vraiment que
dans certaines circonstances,
sous certains ordres,
dans une certaine situation,
on peut perdre complètement
ses valeurs initiales, face...
C'est même pas de l'obéissance,
c'est une situation
plus que de l'obéissance.
L'obéissance, c'est plus
l'expérience de Milgram, d'ailleurs.
Mais celle de Zimbardo,
elle montre plutôt que le contexte,
la situation et la manière
dont se déroulent les choses
peuvent faire
qu'on a un changement
dans notre comportement
et nos valeurs.
Et c'est intéressant aussi,
pour comprendre
un peu mieux l'histoire.
[Musique]
En cinquième,
on va parler de ce qu'avait
constaté Henry Beecher
durant la seconde
guerre mondiale.
C'était un anesthésiste.
Et c'est à lui qu'on doit la première
découverte de l'effet placebo.
Donc l'effet placebo,
c'est le fait de prendre
un médicament qui n'en est pas un.
Qui est juste
du sucre et de l'eau.
Et de ressentir quand même
des effets bénéfiques.
Lui, il s'en est rendu compte
quand il s'est aperçu
que les soldats qui étaient blessés
et qui allaient rentrer chez eux,
souffraient moins que d'autres
soldats qui étaient moins blessés
et qui allaient pas
rentrer chez eux.
Et en fait, il s'est dit :
"Okay, l'anticipation fait qu'ils prennent
leurs blessures pour une bonne chose.
Et apparemment ils se sentent
mieux par rapport à ça".
Des expériences pour
comprendre cette psychologie,
un petit peu particulière
ont été faites.
Et aujourd'hui par exemple,
tous les labos de pharmacies
doivent tester en double-aveugle.
Ce qu'on appelle
en double-aveugle,
c'est à dire d'un côté, un placebo
et d'un côté le vrai médicament.
Mais personne ne sait
ce qu'il prend.
ça permet de constater,
si c'est un médicament
qui a un effet placebo de base
ou s'il a vraiment
des choses qui sont actives
et qui fonctionnent à l'intérieur.
Et en faisant ça, on s'est aperçu
d'autres choses,
dont on parle assez rarement.
Et c'est pour ça que
je me suis dit que
c'était cool d'apporter
cette réflexion ici.
Pour qu'un médicament
soit vraiment efficace,
il faut que la personne soit au courant
qu'elle prenne ce médicament.
Et qu'elle soit au courant
de ce que le médicament
va faire ou guérir chez elle.
Si la personne prend un médicament
et qu'elle ne le sait pas.
Par exemple sur
un lit d'hôpital, en perfusion.
Et bien le médicament
aura moins d'effet.
Et ça c'est pas que l'effet placebo
qui se passe dans la tête.
Parce qu'on a
tendance à dire :
"L'effet placebo,
c'est que psychologique".
Pas du tout.
ça va aussi déclencher
dans le cerveau,
quelque chose de très concret.
Qui sont des antalgiques
cérébraux vers le cerveau
qui fabrique ses propres
antalgiques, des opioïdes.
qui vont soulager
du coup la douleur.
Mais ça, il le fait
par anticipation,
parce qu'il sait qu'il est
en train de se faire traiter.
Donc l'effet placebo,
c'est un peu plus complexe
que ce qu'il n'y paraît.
C'était cool d'en parler.
[Musique]
La prochaine expérience,
c'est le point de départ.
c'est Colin Cherry,
qui en 1950
a démontré que l'oreille savait
distinguer des sons dans la masse,
pour pouvoir filtrer en fait,
juste une information
parmi toutes les autres.
Okay ?
En gros, quand vous êtes
dans une soirée.
Genre vous êtes dans un bar,
il y a du bruit de partout.
Et pourtant vous parlez
peut-être avec quelqu'un
qui à l'autre bout de la table.
Et vous suivez votre conversation,
comme si tout le brouhaha
autour n'existait pas,
et comme si c'était
un peu un tas de sons,
mais qui n'avaient pas
trop de sens, en fait.
Et alors que c'est très clair,
ce que l'autre vous dit.
Du coup en 1958, Donald Broadbent
a voulu aller un petit peu plus loin
en menant des expériences
un peu plus complexes.
Parce que la majorité
des psychologues de l'époque
pensaient que le cerveau
ne savait pas traiter
plusieurs flux d'informations
en même temps.
Et que okay, il y avait
peut-être un filtre comme ça,
mais ce filtre était unique.
Il pouvait pas traiter deux
informations en même temps.
Et lui, il a démontré l'inverse.
En fait c'est très simple, il a demandé
à des participants de venir.
Il leur a mis un casque sur les oreilles,
mais en fait c'est un double casque.
Ils entendaient des suites
de chiffres de chaque côté.
Genre 314 d'un côté,
628 de l'autre.
Mais tout ça en simultané.
Et malgré le fait
que ce soit en simultané,
ils savaient dissocier
les deux chiffres
et ils pouvaient les noter
ou les répéter au fur et à mesure.
Tant que les informations
restent simples,
le cerveau peut avoir
plusieurs filtres en même temps.
Et les écouter et les dissocier.
Dès que ça devient
un petit peu complexe.
Et c'est ce qu'a fait
Donald Broadbent en 1958.
Après il a accéléré le truc.
Et il a rendu les informations
plus complexes.
Et là, il y a ce qu'on appelle le Filtre
de Broadbent qui se met en place
et qui fait qu'on arrive
à se concentrer que sur un seul
et qu'on occulte
complètement l'autre.
On le perçoit,
mais on ne le comprend pas.
Comme quand on parle
avec quelqu'un dans une soirée,
où des fois, vous savez
vous avez une conversation
et en même temps vous saisissez
un ou deux mots très simples.
Parce ce que ça vous
intéresse sur le côté.
C'est le filtre de Broadbent.
[Musique]
Il nous reste plus
qu'une seule expérience.
Je voulais vous parler
de l'Hypothèse de Sapir-whorf.
Il est parti d'un principe
très simple.
Les esquimaux ont plus
d'une centaine de mots,
pour désigner des
neiges différentes,
qu'on n'est même pas nous,
capables de percevoir.
Mais comme là, la vidéo commence
à être un petit peu longue,
pour ce genre de vidéo.
Je vous raconterai ça
sur mon Instagram,
sur lequel vous pouvez
me rejoindre.
Et si ça vous intéresse pas
Instagram, ne stressez pas.
J'en parlerai un jour sur la chaîne.
Mais en attendant, je vais le faire
en story dès aujourd'hui,
comme ça vous pourrez
le revoir ou en vidéo en dur.
Si vous ne connaissiez pas,
je m'appelle Fabien Olicard,
vous pouvez vous abonner
à la chaîne, c'est gratuit.
Et vous pouvez activer la cloche,
comme ça vous savez
que les autres vidéos sortent.
Vous pouvez liker cette vidéo.
Pensez à me dire
si vous voulez un épisode 2.
Voilà, puisque si vous voulez pas,
ça sert à rien d'en faire un deuxième.
Mais si vous voulez,
j'en fais un deuxième.
Et ici, je vous mets deux autres vidéos
qui peuvent vous intéresser.
ça c'est une vidéo
sur l'effet Mandela,
qui fait qu'on a l'impression
que le passé a été modifié.
Et ça c'est une vidéo
sur l'effet Dorian Gray,
qui dit que potentiellement,
notre prénom,
notre signe astrologique
peuvent nous influencer.
Mais scientifiquement parlant.
Bref, c'est assez passionnant.
A très bientôt,
Ciao !